abone ol
Bu
grupta anlatamadım
Vallahi ben öğrenmiş olduk gibi bana
değer verip alacağınız
zaman zaman olmuyor
tabi bu unutma
ilgi duymadığım zaman bir eski askerler
eski Sporcular dünya şampiyonları
kendimize yalnız Melike
bu duyguları
yaşam sevincinin azalmasına ve sağlık o
yönden dolayı bu dünyada göç ettiklerine
sebep oluyor böyle örnekler vardır
yaşında 60 65 70 yaşına kadar bölüyorum
eski sporcularda değer verilme dikleri
için
kendileri bu ülke için her tarafında
sakat deyip
rahatsızlıklar geçirip makarnalar alır
dünya seviyesinde
kaldı bir kenara altı karışık
rahatsızlıklar uyuyorlar ve ben buna
sporcunun limon ve süpürgesi diyorum o
yüzden böyle hatırladığınız için bu bana
gençlik aşısı gibi oluyor gelebilir
yeniden hissediyorum ve biliyorsunuz
yakında üçüncü köprüden
suyun altında
24/31 da
son
dakika haberleri ile
7/24 saat sabah yapacak
bir şey yok biliyor musun benim
mesela en son
10000/12 buçuk metre
[Müzik]
bunları Yapma ya
ve dokuz senelik SAT Komandosu yedim
bari bir sene kaldım al
Deniz Kuvvetleri 12 yaşındayken gördüm
17'de
[Müzik]
ve eğer sporcunun önündeydim
zaten
olimpiyatta mücadele etmekten var ya ben
ayrıldım gittin alan milli takımıyla
çalışıyorum ben çok sevdiler geleceğim
29 yaşındayım Ondan sonra artık
ayrı
60 63
bu allahım bak ben olimpiyatlarla Sakın
bu kadar hissediyorum
Allah'ım Instagram'da bir yanlışlık olsa
da beni sat birliğini geliş alsınlar
diye dua
düşünüyorum hayallerle almaya
giderken
maaşı
barışık tazminatı
onları bırakıp
döndüm o
[Müzik]
bir antrenman bilimi vücudu arttırma
bölümlerini bir antrenman
spor
[Müzik]
bundan sonra da Türkiye'de millet-i
bu etmiyorsun hakkında Bence hanımefendi
gasbaş Amerika'da bunları planlarını
alıyoruz zamanlarda Türkiye'ye gelip
saat atölyelerinde imal edilip bunları
ve bütün askeri birliklere yolculuk
Türkiye'deki askeri birliklere kara hava
deniz anda
bundan sonra
öğretmek ve
kitapları yapmaya başladım bunu yaparken
Amerika'da şu altında 30603
oy oranımız Albay Amerika'da Bıçağın
oldukça demek ise
gitmiş ben yüzüyorum
dünyada en hızlı
[Müzik]
değilim yani
dönüşümde
görüşürüz
spor
sporla ilgili
problemler
bazı şeyleri
rekor kırma başka bir
yardımcı olur mu bu
gözüme Geri döndüğümde ama siliyorlar
döndüm ya böyle geceleri yaptığında o
bir olmalı günlerimiz askeri eğitimleri
sevdiğim arkadaşlarımızı bak bir asker
de Birbirimizin arkasında kolları Sana
gidiyoruz 8 10 12 14 16 vardır Bizim
arkamızda vardır yandan
daha iyi ki
Sen niye ağlarda kalmadı dersen ben ilk
önce çok seviyorum ülkemde bir parçacık
attım olurdu
antrenman bitiminde Olsun olsun geniş
telefonlarında olsun beslenmeli olsun
binlerce
bir
[Müzik]
şey yok mu
ve 13 bir yola istiyorlar biliyor musun
13 bin dolar istiyorlar gelmek için bir
de yedi gün kalıyor üstün bir Erdoğan
ise adam şirketi kurmuş
rekor kıran herkese Sertifikayı alıyor
getiriyor Mesela en uzağa tükürene
veriyorsa
tuvalet yapanın da işte en uzun Dans
edelim mi en uzun süre öpüşen inen çok
yemek Tamam
[Müzik]
yeter ki sen para yolluyor O yüzden
bizim şimdi Türkiye'de yeni onları
Derneği
kuruldu yine
bu denli
fakir
geliştirmesinin bana yollayacağım bir
sertifika değil
Eğer Türkiye'ye bağlı dernekler masasına
bağlı kurulmuş gider ne verdiği Turkcell
daha çok önemli bir oradan da aldım ve
Beni tanıyorlar tabi 18
mesela bugüne kadar
iki köpeği bağlayan o
zaman 38'e
bu çıkmadan Boğazı gibi bütün Boğazı
suyun altından yüzük aksaraya kadar 500x
yok
4627 yüz Ocak 24 saat orada suyun
altında üstüne atlayacağım şimdi bir
poligonda yeşil da
Allah Allah sağlık verirse ölene kadar
bu restoranlardan kıracağım ama
kırılmayacak rekorları kırıyorum
şimdi hesapta analiz kaldı çok önemli 24
tane saat prensibi vardır olmak için
bilgilere baktırabilir
öyle
yaparız Bir plan yaparız bir analiz
yaparız analiz yaparken Mesela bir tane
şundan alayım Boğaz Köprüsü'nden atladı
Boğaz Köprüsü'ne atlayacağım metre kaç
metre yüksektedir
neresinden atlayacağım ki mesela köprüye
yakın
noktası daha güzel ama ortadan atlarsan
trafik var
köprüde ortak
Balıkçı motorları Turizm motorları
geçiyorum bunu yaparken paraşütü
açılması için 150 metre mesafe ve
O benim atlayacağım biraz bunların
hesabını yapıp paraşütü çabuk açılacak
şekilde kalkıyorsun bazı parçaların
oluyorsun ben bir su altında ağırlık
kaldırma rekoru yaptım 24 saat su
altında
kaldı 308 309 309 26 çıkmalı harflerle
şimdi ne kadar kaldırdım hesapladım
suyun kaldırma gücünü hesap ama
harfleri kaldırırken
birazdan ölürse
[Müzik]
yani 24 18
şu ana kadar
elektrik su doğalgaz ne kadar buraya
neler alacağım spor aletleri hazerleme
ikincisi ve
[Müzik]
Apple mı
bu yerleştir Sen her şeyi hepsini yerine
göre zamanlamasını gökyüzü atları
Harekat planı
aktiviteleri lokasyonları ve ondan sonra
biraz
ben sapların en yaşlılarından biriyim ya
benden oldukları dağıtmış
Şimdi bence
o kadar şey o
o gözyaşlarına alışmak Böylelikle
acilter kan ve gözyaşıyla bir tane varsa
Savaşçının gözyaşları bir
nokta com dan onu ıslatıyoruz akvaryum
olmak için
Bence her
Amerika
yoksa ben de yüzlerce katmamız var
Hepsini çok seviyorum Hepsini
gözlerinden öpüyorum
Ben
artık anladım anladım